but we have some good news for
conservatives though this this might
change the game here we got the story
from the hill
florida passes bill prohibiting social
media companies from banning politicians
it's way more than that i don't i don't
think people realize that
sb 7072 now there's some really
interesting weird stuff they put in it
they like amended it to include
if you have a theme park you're excluded
from this or something
well disney's kind of cool right so what
is facebook
uh face park facebook will open space
park
and twitter will open twitter world to
try and get past this
because it's not just about politicians
this also protects news organizations
so this is fascinating i've got i've got
sb 7072 pulled up
and it's kind of annoying to go through
the whole thing
but it's it's also has something to do
with like antitrust
let me see if i can just pull up a
journalistic enterprise there we go
check this out journalistic enterprise
according to this new bill
means an entity doing business in
florida that publishes an excess of 100
000 words available online
with at least 50 000 paid subscribers or
100 000 monthly active users publishes
100 hours of audio or video
available online with at least 100
million viewers annually
that's us and the other one is you the
post millennium
i'm pretty sure you have more than 100
000 monthly active users you probably
get that on a single article i'd imagine
yeah
that means if you were operating in
florida
wikipedia could not remove you from
sources you could not be banned from
twitter
so let me let me make sure i pull this
up because there have been some changes
but my understanding is that a
journalistic enterprise
can't be banned based on their uh
opinions the content of their articles
so
so that would be like the new york post
was was uh suppressed and banned on
facebook it was banned on twitter their
account was taken down for a little
while
that was in the fall with the hunter
biden stuff i think that was so
interesting i think that opened a lot of
people's eyes to what was going on
with social media and with suppression
and with you know
fact checking and with the control that
social media companies
really have in the marketplace of ideas
right now they can decide
if an idea lives or dies or is exposed
to the public or not
i think desantis is pretty fascinating
guy i appreciate that he just
goes for it on so many policies i liked
what he did with this whole covet thing
he was just like
nope what concerns me about
this uh bill is that people would just
stop
operating in florida like if i ran
facebook i'd be like all right not
operate in florida
yeah i found it interesting i found it
they say a social media platform may not
take any action to sensor d
platform or shadow ban a journalistic
enterprise based on the content of its
publication or broadcast
post prioritization which is the
algorithm of certain journalistic
enterprise content based on payments to
the social media platform by such
journalistic enterprise is not a
violation of this paragraph
this paragraph does not apply if the
condor material is obscene as defined
in s84701 so there's some exclusions but
this will be the end of wikipedia as we
know it do you think
yeah let's just go down so this
wikipedia i don't think should be
protected by section 230.
no i don't think so either so because i
don't think that i don't think they are
a platform i think they're clearly a
publisher
well so for uh specifically let's let's
jump over to the critical race theory
article we already had pulled up oh
let's take a look it says
critical race theory from wikipedia the
free encyclopedia
it doesn't say from user joe you know
joe bob jr
or jim joe bob jr that's joe biden he's
joe bob
you know joe biden's actually joe bob jr
yeah joseph robinette biden jr
anyway i digress it says from wikipedia
so my argument is
just because i submit a comment if if i
if i comment to the new york times and
they publish in an article and it says
the new york times
you know article and then it puts my
words there like that's from them
right not from me so this is interesting
wikipedia
won't allow you to use certain sources
i'm
probably i'd be willing to make a
substantial that the poster millennial
is not a lot of wikipedia
i think we have an entry no no i mean
like your articles right
can't be used oh they can't citations
no because they'll say it's not reliable
really is that right
can we not be used as a source i don't
know about you specifically
so there's a lot of boundaries that are
not allowed media matters is considered
credible but biased news guard considers
media matters
a-ok credible but wikipedia has a lot of
sources that are deemed not
credible and they can't be used or if
they're not
certified credible you can't use them
either they'll they'll challenge these
news outlets
okay can't do that no more under this
new bill in florida
if your organization operates in florida
wikipedia can't remove
your content on the can't remove your
stories in the basement
basis of the content so perhaps they
could argue no no we've banned the
outlet outright
right what's the reason for banning the
outlet we don't consider them reliable
because of the content they pop up the
bill says you can't do that
which would mean you would look at
critical race theory
anything could be added from the
post-millennial anything could be added
from gateway pundit or from the daily
wire or the
thing that you end up with though is you
end up with editors on wikipedia you end
up with the uh
you know it you you can end up in weird
wikipedia wars where you go in and
change something
and then the editor who had it there in
the first place goes in and changes it
and these can this can go on for a long
time
and this is where the interesting
lawsuits erupt with this sb
7072 they say that
users have to be given a bunch of
special provisions like
they have to be informed as to why
they're being removed they have to be
given access to all their data made
available immediately if they don't they
can be sued
i think as soon as desantis signs this
you're gonna have
you know jim bob with one follower sign
up or zero followers
post something outrageous get banned and
immediately file a lawsuit
and then they will get slammed by
probably hundreds of lawsuits overnight
they won't be able to deal with well
what would happen then in the courts i
mean what how would they deal with that
well so we have a fine system aren't
they isn't it like yeah it's a hundred
times
a hundred thousand dollar fine or ten
thousand dollar fine depending on if you
suppress
either that or they'll just open
everything up and not ban anything
and that would kind of be i think a
better situation i think that's probably
the goal of it
is to have just have a much more free
and open
ideas so the library online there's a
funny meme
where it's uh the npc meme you've never
seen it where it's like the npc face and
then a guy responds and then angry npc
face
and he says my opinions are being
censored on the internet he's wearing a
mug ahead
right and then the uh the normal guy
says and what opinions are those
and then the npc gets an angry face well
they're trying to imply
because there's other memes that are
similar that conservatives are only
complaining because they're racists
right well that's always the argument
but it's not true no but it also doesn't
matter if it's not true
because once you get called some of
these things there's no way to walk it
back
you know there was a what was it like a
couple of years ago or whatever there
was this weather man
who said the wrong thing and he didn't
mean to say the wrong thing
it was just the way that his mouth
formed the words there were there it was
like
it was like a a freudian portman two of
two words right but he didn't even mean
it it was just
it was like a weird linguistic thing and
john mccorder who is a linguist at
columbia university
um came out and said actually this is a
pretty
common thing that happens this is a
weird way that your mouth moves the
way that language sort of works in your
mouth it was like a very
and dude lost his job but so so so the
issue is because it didn't matter
like it doesn't matter the only thing
that matters are the appearances
well in a very shallow culture right now
right right right but but
in this capacity what i what i'm
bringing up is conservatives getting
banned for their political opinions
it's not just because they're racist
like you get banned for saying learn to
code
for criticizing journalists they will
remove you from these platforms
many people who did not break the rules
but were bombastic got banned from
social media
and they claimed some arbitrary or or
you know vague understanding of the
rules
notably in the case or outright lies
according to james o'keefe
because they banned him supposedly so
twitter says for operating multiple
accounts and james is now suing them for
this
right i thought that was really
interesting too and i think he's got a
lot of nerve for doing that i respect it
absolutely
and that you saw they launched pv legal
so no no i didn't see that so actually
we had james on the show uh-huh and i
mentioned maybe we do something like the
people's defamation defense fund or
something
oh great and then james was like i'm
gonna do it so he did it
so sweet good for him but the the main
point is
conservatives lose they're going to lose
because they're excised from political
discourse
trump's some of his biggest supporters
were not allowed to rally people and
communicate and post online they got
banned from across the board right
and the most extreme leftists were
allowed to stay on and say crazy
and they didn't say crazy things
violence call for violence organizing
violence well and there's all of these
antifa accounts as well
that just call for you know when there's
going to be protests and things and tell
everyone where to go
um and then show up and that you know
this is something andy now works on a
lot uh
with um another one of our reporters mia
cassell
and they're tracking this all the time
they're tracking these
uh you know events that are just
organized out in public
and then you had the situation with um
you know the capital riot the january
6th which is
of course the worst thing that has ever
happened in this country since the civil
war you guys so
just be aware of that yeah you heard
that right so the president said it so
it's got to be true
um but after that you had like this
massive purge of people you had them
taking down
an entire social media platform saying
you know they took down parlor from
amazon took it off its servers it got
banned from the app stores
uh i think it's back now but the idea
was that
all of this horrible stuff had been
planned online on parlor
and it turned out to be primarily
planned on facebook
and nothing happened to facebook did
they maybe crack down a little more i
don't know
twitter sure did but you know there's
just no accountability
on the left at all it's just assumed
that if they miss something then that's
just in good faith and they're trying
really hard
and they're so clearly come down on the
on the conservative side
conservatives need to stop cooperating
in their system the way i see it is
imagine you're playing monopoly with
someone
and they're the banker and they just
like reach in and pull out a 500 and put
in their opponent you're like yeah i
just saw you took that money and they go
end
right and then you're like okay whatever
i guess right look dude like imagine
you're sitting around like five people
this is how i play monopoly with my son
he's like mom i'm taking money out of
the bank
so imagine you've got five people and
you're sitting there watching the banker
take the money you're going dudes
he's taking the money out he's cheating
and then he looks you in the eye as he
hands 100 to the friend in the front his
friend goes
i don't see anything right it's just
like why are you going to keep playing
this
where you've got the banker and the
media together and the politicians right
but here's the question what other game
is there the conservatives allowed
culture to just be
thoroughly created by the left all of
the platforms everything are created by
the left and then as soon as they create
one
it gets banned it's because when the
game started we started playing monopoly
this left disc goes uh or this democrat
could say democracy
i'll be the banker and everyone went
sure and the republic was like i don't
know about that
whatever i guess and then they play a
game and they cheat and the conservative
goes like
well i'll win next time and they cheat
again right meanwhile the conservative
could have been like
hey at least two other people playing
this game are concerned you guys want to
go play
katan or something right and just walk
away and go so now you see the daily
wire making movies
sure no which i think is great right
exactly i think that's
playing their game stop trying to pander
to these people they're not going to let
you in the club
but then what happens but then what
happens too is we have a complete
polarization
of media so now we basically have like
when i talk to
you know liberals they don't even read
the same news that i read
they don't even see the same things when
i go on to
um you know i think i was saying before
there was a i saw a panel
conversation on one like cnn or msnbc or
whatever it was
and it was yamiche alcindor uh who's pbs
white house correspondent and a couple
of other people and they were talking
about how
the gop is the party of fear that
they're trying to make everyone
terrified and they're playing culture
wars games
and i'm looking at this and i'm going
your guys just told me that it was a
patriotic duty to wear a mask
and that i need to be terrified to send
my kid back to school until literally
everyone in the country is vaccinated
and you're telling me that us saying
that
you know critical race theory is not a
great idea is is
us being this party of fear it's
absolutely ridiculous
we don't see the same news we don't
consume the same media at all
the tr the the traditional liberals
don't watch the news at all
they're getting their news second hand
oh absolutely you don't think they're
reading the times every day
washington post absolutely not and
that's why they're clueless about what's
going on
that's why they just follow the trends
and that's what trends that's why they
go back to sleep the moment biden wins
i think that they are reading the times
every day i think they are reading wapo
and they're watching cnn
and they're consuming all of their media
this way they're watching rachel maddow
they're doing all of that stuff
and that's where they're getting their
you know that's where they're getting
their confirmation
that they're correct i think i think
it's people like following alyssa milano
do people really follow alyssa mullen
got a million followers did you see how
she got destroyed the other day by that
uh lady on tv
that was pretty sweet because is a
hardcore unrepentant racist
and i mean that literally right i'm not
i'm not i'm not she also totally
betrayed the whole me too thing when she
was like
well tara reid's probably basically a
big liar
okay i love how rose mcgowan is always
calling her out right rose is great
spectacular um you know and she's not a
big fan of republican she criticizes
them as well but alyssa said a whole
bunch of
really really racist things and that
woman the black woman calls her out
for saying like she like also basically
said that all black men are criminals
like just really hardcore racist stuff
but from with with like this this this
pandering
could you imagine like kind of voice
like condescending in race at the same
time it's
brutal she also was wasn't she snapped
wearing a crochet mask
because that's really going to keep the
spike proteins out
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you